Welcome,
welcome in.
Welcome back to another edition of Market Takes.
I know you could have been anywhere in the world,
but you're here with me and I appreciate that.
Thank you so much for being with us on market takes listen,
today we are diving into the state of housing.
We're talking about the interplay with inflation and we are looking at the US housing
market through the release of today's us existing home sales report
big release because the overwhelming majority of all homes sold our existing homes.
So we are breaking that down.
I know if you've been looking and reading the headlines,
it seems like it's all bad news,
but the real news,
there's some good and some bad.
We're going to get into all of that because that's what we do here on market take.
So listen,
we are going to talk through what today's existing home sales report showed.
We're going to talk about the overall state of housing,
the big picture,
we're going to check in on the markets because we're going to see what investors are thinking about how they're reading
today's report.
And then we're going to talk about the overall role of housing in inflation,
the big picture because that's what it's all about,
right?
It's all about what's happening with inflation because the fed is watching inflation and the fed is basically what's
moving everything.
So we're gonna talk about that.
Of course,
I'm gonna tell you what to look out for next because even though it's backward looking data,
we are always looking forward.
Uh and that's really what we're gonna do today here on market take.
So thanks again for being with us.
Listen,
today's report showed home sales,
home sales failed to 4.4 million in March.
Now want to throw a chart up here on your screen and just give you a look at the overall trend.
Now,
this goes back about a year and as you can see starting April 2022 you're just seeing
consistent declining,
declining,
declining until January even goes a little bit below.
And then that February number boom,
that's a 15.4% increase from January to February and then a
small decrease from February to March.
Now,
what we have seen is there was a 2.4% decrease from February to
March and that was lower than expectations.
Actually,
expectations were for about 4.5 million homes sold was 4.44.
But,
and sales also declined 22% from a year before.
If we had gone all the way back to that March 2022 report,
you would have seen that.
So you see the overall trend lower but do not be
fooled.
What we have seen is consistently still high,
high reports.
As you see up there on your screen,
the March reading is the highest.
If not for that big jump in February,
this would be the highest reading that we had seen since October of last year.
And also overall prices ticked up to 375,700.
That was higher than February's increase,
which was the first decrease that we had seen in 131 months.
So this chart is illustrating the overall trend which had been lower and now is picking
back up.
And even though it decreased this month,
we are still holding at those much higher levels in terms of the number of homes sold.
So the other big piece to watch is this February was a big month that may have marked a
turning point in the housing market where people stop being so bearish and saying,
you know what buying a house isn't for me and said,
hey,
you know what maybe it is.
Uh you saw that ended streak of 131 consecutive months,
almost 11 straight years of prices going up every single month,
year over year.
That is the longest or it was the longest streak on record.
But now we've seen an increase of housing prices again suggest that that decrease we saw last
month may have been an aberration,
an unusual phenomenon in the data.
We are seeing prices pick back up again.
So you saw that decline small but still prices went back up and
holding at higher levels.
Those are the big pieces that you need to take from this report.
If you were going to take away anything from the report,
we're going to get a little more down into the data,
a lot more down into the data.
But if you walk away with one big picture takeaway from this report,
it is that,
that we are seeing a small decline from February but still holding at much higher levels than
where we had been.
And the trend has been thrown off and we are no longer seeing a declining,
consistent,
declining year,
over year,
month,
over month sales of existing home sales.
Another big trend that you want to watch out for and want to throw a chart up here on your
screen to give you an idea of what we're looking at in the markets.
This is the US Home Builders Index.
Uh the Dow Jones,
us Home Builder Index basically.
Uh this index marks all watches all the big US home builders.
We're talking uh K B home,
we're talking uh what are some of the other ones?
D R Horton Toll Brothers,
some of those big names.
Those are all what makes up this index,
the big home building companies.
Uh There you were just seeing a big huge takeoff and increase in prices.
It's been one of the strongest sectors over the past year.
Over the past one year time frame,
this index is up almost 36% and today it's up over 4%
4.3% increase today.
So long term,
this has been a big increase and you're seeing the stock of home builders rise that tells you
that investors see home builders and homes,
more construction,
more building more sales,
all those things for home builders.
That's a good thing.
If you own those stocks,
it may not be such a good thing if you're looking to buy a home.
So that chart illustrating what we've seen overall from the home builder index and what
investors stock pickers stock buyers think about the US housing market.
They think that things are about to go up in a big way,
which means higher prices likely on homes,
more competition.
The one good thing you could take about take away from that though.
If you're looking at buying a home,
you're someone who's in the housing market hoping for a decline in inflation.
That also when those home builder stocks rise,
that means they build more homes,
which means we get more supply.
One thing that we have had is a consistently low level of supply as in not a lot of
houses on the market for sale.
Well,
if those home builders get bullish and as we saw last week if you watch or sorry.
Beginning of this week,
if you watch market takes the US home builder index showed confidence starting to pick back up
prices,
starting to pick back up could mean more supplies coming into the market.
This could be potentially good news for home buyers.
We saw the total housing inventory in March 980,000 units just a little bit under
one million units.
That's up 1% from February and 5.4% from a year ago.
Unsold inventory is at about a 2.6 month pace.
That is still very low historically,
but that is up from two months uh inventory that we had in March
2022.
So housing housing supply is slowly but surely increasing.
Uh Here's the bad news though,
on the other side of that,
you are seeing more folks stepping in and buying that.
So even as we are getting a little bit more supply,
we're seeing a lot more demand and every time those interest rates go down just a little
bit,
those market,
those mortgage rates go down just a little bit.
We're going to talk about that in a second.
You're seeing people jump in and seeing a lot of folks buying and looking to
buy and,
and making that a real crowded marketplace once
again.
So speaking of marketplaces want to throw up one more thing here on your screen and that is we're going to take a
look at the live markets,
what's happening in markets right now.
So I want to just highlight a couple of things here.
You see overall stocks are down,
but you see this difference here between what we got on the Dow and what we've got in the NASDAQ.
So when we're looking at the Dow,
right,
the Dow Jones industrial average,
you see,
it hits its low point of day right around 10 AM when this existing home sales report comes out and
then you see prices just really picking back up.
You've seen a lot of some of that come off,
but we didn't see that in the NASDAQ and we didn't see it as much in the S and P.
Now,
why is that?
Well,
the Dow,
the Dow Jones industrial average or the N Y S C has about 21 home building companies.
The Dow has more of those home builders than the NASDAQ.
NASDAQ only has nine total home building companies and a lot of them are pretty small on it.
Whereas the Dow has a lot more of those home builders in it.
And that's why you're seeing that divergence between the Dow and the NASDAQ.
Now,
when we also look out here at bonds,
right,
let's take a look at bonds.
We're seeing yields coming down.
We're seeing overall that means prices are going back up.
People are buying bonds and really what that means is risk off.
We are seeing a decline in risk appetite.
You see it here with crypto just negative all in the red across the board.
The more you get out on the risk scale on some of these coins,
the more you see that big decrease in crypto prices.
Another thing you're going to want to watch for is commodities.
As you look out right here in commodities,
you're seeing crude oil down across the board.
We're also seeing lower prices in copper dr copper as it's known since about that
10 PM point.
You're seeing a decline,
that's less about this report and more about the leading economic indicators
report that we also got at 10 AM that showed another
decline the 12th month in a row with a negative reading.
If you go back to the last 15 months on leading economic indicators,
only February 2022 is more than zero.
Folks,
these are recession levels historically,
if you look back and we've had a recession,
we are at recession levels on the leading economic indicators.
And I think that's why you're seeing some of this risk off in crude.
You're seeing it in uh copper prices,
which is a measure of the economy and you're seeing gold right here,
pick back up.
Uh as you see,
folks buy gold when things are worried so that just illustrating how investors are seeing the data that
we've gotten out on the market so far.
And what we're talking about when it comes to the outlook going forward in the market.
We can't go on today without talking about how this influences and
impacts things for the Federal Reserve.
The fed,
listen,
when we look out at fed funds futures,
basically what investors are betting the fed will do.
They are believing that the fed is locked in for May that next month when the fed meets and
they're going to announce it on May 3rd.
The investors say the fed is locked in for a 25 basis point increase of
rates.
87% of investors see that as the likely outcome.
But when you look out further,
you were seeing expectations for more cuts.
A lot of folks had bet that the fed was going to start cutting rates as soon as July,
those expectations have been kind of pushed back a little bit into August.
But what folks are saying very clearly is they expect the Federal Reserve to raise rates next month and
then start cutting them back and that's having a direct impact on housing because if the
Fed cuts rates,
that means mortgage rates start to get lower.
Investors in the 10 year Treasury have already gotten out ahead of that and started reducing and
buying more 10 year treasuries,
which is bringing down the yield,
which raises the prices.
And that's what we're seeing.
Wanna put one more thing up here on your screen and that is the 30 year fixed
mortgage rate.
As you can see that just spiked up,
uh as we got through 2022 into 2023 it's kind of come down a little bit but
very clearly on your screen there.
You see well above 6% still more than double where we were in early
2021 even at the beginning of 2022 so mortgage rates are
still very high.
Historically,
we're higher than we've been anywhere in the last 10 years as you see on your screen.
But anytime mortgage rates come down,
you're seeing buyers very,
very sensitive to price and you see that little decline there at the edge of your screen.
That's what's prompting a lot of this buying and some of this boom you're seeing in home builder stock.
So that just illustrating again how the market has responded,
the overall mortgage market and how investors have responded and that's
pushed the mortgage rate down.
That's allowed some more folks to buy in,
but really not a big change as you can see in the overall environment
for mortgages,
for housing prices,
but it's having that psychological impact.
People see mortgage rates go down just a little bit and they rush out to buy and you're seeing pick
ups in the overall rate of housing purchases that could throw the fed off of
what they want to do.
The fed wants people to not take out mortgages,
not go out and buy homes,
not refinance their house to go out and buy some more things,
maybe refinish the deck,
maybe make some home improvements.
They don't want you to do that.
They want you to stay home.
Say,
wow,
these prices are too,
I need to fall back and just let things settle down.
People aren't doing that.
That could have big implications on the rate of inflation.
Listen,
housing A K A shelter is what they call it in the C P I.
The consumer price index housing is about 30 is about one third of that.
It's exactly 32.77% of the overall C P I
metric.
But about one third of C P I and core C P I,
which is what the fed looks at even more closely.
The Shelter index last month accounted for over 60% of the total
increase in core CPI.
So we saw even as overall CPI inflation decline,
we saw that core number pick up excluding food and energy and 60% of that,
more than 60% of that was due to housing.
So we are seeing housing prices start to pick back up again,
moving in the opposite direction of what the Fed wants.
That could have implications for inflation.
Obviously,
this is people's biggest,
biggest outlay,
the biggest thing they spend money on each month that could have big for the Fed and for the
market.
So that's why you want to watch housing prices.
That's why you want to watch what's happening here and mortgage rates and all that good stuff.
Another thing to watch out for energy prices.
We saw energy down a little bit today,
but we're back at that 80 level.
We have seen oil prices really pick back up and rise over the past few months.
That will be something to watch out for energy,
not as important in the CPI and overall inflation,
but it has a big role in market psychology when people see the prices at the pump at the pump rising,
they think,
oh man,
prices are going back up.
My sentiment is lower.
I don't want to go out and buy as much because I'm having to spend so much here on gas.
That's a very big psychological impact.
And it also tells people inflation is probably going back up.
I need to ask the boss for a bigger raise.
I need to look for a new job that pays more because I can't deal with this high inflation.
Watch out for oil prices there.
Um So listen,
the bad news.
This really,
this report suggests that inflation could be picking back up housing prices which are a big piece
could increase inflation and cause the fed to have to do more to tighten more to raise rates.
The good news,
this could mean the increased bullish sentiment for home builders could mean more
building more supply and that could bring prices down for home
buyers and prospective homeowners.
Listen,
what to look out for next All right,
we have a big report coming on the fed's discount window bar later today at 4
30 we get that number.
That's definitely something you're going to want to watch out for.
Because the Fed again,
while they're raising rates,
they're also pumping a ton of money into the financial system.
They have pumped almost 400 or over $300 billion into the banking system.
That means that it loosens financial conditions and makes it harder for them to affect
policy with their interest rates.
Loosening financial conditions could mean tougher financial conditions for small businesses,
for banks,
for consumers,
even as they're making things looser for big banks,
for big corporations,
all those folks.
So you're going to want to watch that number out today at 4 30.
The Fed's balance sheet is approaching $9 trillion.
That would be a record high.
That would be big.
You also,
we've got new home sales coming on Tuesday and next week and manufacturing and services PM I
those purchasing managers index,
those are on Friday earnings reports next week.
I'm sorry,
this week we've got Procter and Gamble and l'oreal coming out on Friday.
That's tomorrow.
Watch out for that next week.
We get Microsoft alphabet,
Amazon Meta.
You also get Exxon and Chevron,
the big oil giants from the US Johnson and Johnson Visa and mastercard.
Many more.
We will break all that down for you on Monday here on market takes,
I hope you'll be with us and listen,
that's gonna do it for this edition.
Like I said,
you could have been anywhere in the world,
but you're here with me and I appreciate that.
Thanks for joining us here on Market takes,
we'll see you next time.